i just want to give a big shout out to
everyone who got mad at me for eating
last episode i apologize that was my
only time to eat
and as a way to say sorry cody and i
have actually ordered a cake and i'm
going to eat it
for the last 30 minutes of the episode
just it's just a happy proposal on it no
i didn't realize it
i didn't realize on my mic it wasn't
there i was like leaning away i didn't
hear it at all
so i thought it was good but apparently
i wasn't
it i mean first off we do apologize
right no yeah excuse for us to be
[ __ ] around the mics
no i at this point no i genuinely did
not
hear it i like actually didn't hear it
but i will say
it is kind of [ __ ] hilarious how mad
people get it
oh bro like i know it is it is that is a
special kind of anger oh what's that
screenshot oh yeah
i was crying bro i have to be
so honest and say i was crying laughing
at your dms
one guy i have a couple things to call
out on that but this guy goes
no one wants to hear that [ __ ] he's
something to the tune like you don't
want to hear that [ __ ] nasty [ __ ]
you ruined my saturday
that's like the whole thing
like the whole day even after like
he's like at night eating dinner and he
just can't
[ __ ] eat this [ __ ] what
what happened i know it's just he's got
a podcast and he's eating on it
what's the what's the podcast
i imagine it like maybe he times out his
or he structures his whole saturday
around
the episode uh and so he couldn't he
couldn't finish the episode because he
was so
now and then he's like well now i got i
got to sit here for 40 minutes
and now what do i do and now what do i
do this is my time to relax yeah now i
gotta
maybe i'll go get lunch and then it just
[ __ ] the whole day yeah and yeah i get
i got you man i'm sorry bro i won't i
won't do that to you again
i do have to say there are a couple
consistencies though
in all the dms all right yeah
overwhelming amount of dudes
predominantly males and there's a
consistent word
across all of your complaints which is
wet
so i don't use that wet that wet it's
like wet wet
wham you gotta wham yeah i got a wet ass
mouth
does it make you uncomfortable my wet
moist lips just
sucking on some cream cheese you guys
are weighing over his
wham that's what it is that's what it is
you don't like you don't like a man
where where when i don't like imagining
getting sucked off
it's like no one's making you mad in
that but the sound just sounds like i'm
getting sucked off
man you you can't say it's not similar
you know i'm just trying to listen to
the podcast you got to ruin my day
because nothing about a dude
i'm thinking about my dick in your mouth
i'm thinking about getting sucked off
man
really really leaning to the su
sucked off you sucked off man
if i'm gonna get sucked off it's gonna
be my my girlfriend
or a girl it's not gonna be while i'm
doing my errands
listening to another man suck me off
sucking me off
[Music]
you know how to go with how to go with
dude she sucked me off
oh my god she was sucking dude she's
sucking and [ __ ] man she
sucks my dick off yeah now i hope the
guy downstairs
yeah yeah now he's just he's got putting
his earbuds in like because the guys are
back
eight months of silence and now it's
sucking off sources suck off
i'm trying to do my work you're up there
sucking around
you're [ __ ] off my day we're just
pissing off everybody
everyone's mad yes dude oh it's hot in
here
yeah i forgot how hot it gets in here
that's that's a lie i wore shorts
because i remembered like the dork i am
i'm like it gets very hot in there
yeah we're tweed pants nice dude this
was the right way he decided to dress
like a finger trap
nice job dude a finger what a finger
finger
yeah i'm wearing juice
he's just pants he's trying to pull them
off and they just suck in your thighs
you're like
oh these are stuck to my legs right now
it was also i had chick-fil-a on the way
here and all right dude i would do that
driving here i was so embarrassed why
because i'm eating it on the way and i
can't eat the
sandwich without the sauce right i do
that right right i got the sauce
going to chick-fil-a for a [ __ ]
reason i'm gonna eat a plain sandwich
yeah and so i'm holding the open sauce
in one hand i'm holding the sandwich in
the other hand and i'm driving with my
knee
unreal and then like cop shows up beside
me so
i put it down on the seat i put the
sandwiches on the [ __ ]
raw leather sick leather seats yeah
that's right [ __ ]
and the sauce and then i spill some on
my pants i'm still driving my with my
knees
my hands are all [ __ ] some hand
sanitizer nice dude
i'm just i'm a piece of garbage you
couldn't just wait five minutes
first of all i have to do that makes me
think of something what
but i want to give to in a second i just
have to walk back to sucking off really
yeah i know sorry please i'd love to go
back to that
i was thinking about and i've i know
we've done this before but
whatever i was thinking about going to a
confessional
it's like ah heavenly father how are you
all right son we want to talk about oh
father
i got my [ __ ] sucked last night
it was so like oh i just felt like i had
to come in and say sorry like it was
she was bad but no i had to apologize
for her you know what i mean
she was sucking my thing he's like
okay well it you know what honestly
father
i didn't even want to really apologize
for it i just had to tell
somebody i'm new to like all my boys are
working yeah
they were answering their phones and i
just thought i'd come in and just
tell you so what do you think well what
does she look like son
he's just tipping the phone around the
[ __ ] around the side let me slide
this through man look at that look at
that he's like oh dear oh dear
you could say man your mercy oh
mercy mercy me
mercy mercy me the lord
oh yeah he's like damn not a lot of
followers too
nice nice she's very uh she's very good
on the instagram i can see
yeah father she sucked my thing
i'm afraid to call her back but because
i don't think she you know
i think i'm just like a little toy to
her but god damn i know would you say
when you say sucked would you say she
sucked you off
oh she slapped me off father
good lord nursing me mercy me
heavenly father i want to apologize for
getting my thing absolutely sucked off
last night
that's a tweet right there dear lord i'm
so sorry for getting completely sucked
last night i have mercy on my soul
please forgive me for getting
sucked off last night father i want to
propose a new chapter in the bible
called the sucking dude that was crazy
she can't be the only one if that's the
devil i need so much more strength
because
good lord
she sucked me off dude
you